hey gang the new ay card game is
available at rug garbage.com right now
do you want to get your loved one the
perfect gift this year that might not
arrive by Christmas cuz we can guarantee
that these probably definitely won't
show up on time we got 50 new questions
to prove whether your family or friends
are absolute trash pick them up at rug
garbage.com
wo do it New York City baby we're doing
the biggest show we've ever done at the
Town Hall theater May 9th grab some
tickets come see the boys stand up
comedy play little a with the crowd yeah
tickets are moving fast everything's
available at arug garbage.com get them
Army of garbage unite New York City
Conneticut New Jersey Delaware Wyoming
wherever you are let's party baby we
love you love you welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan
and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
if they're gr to be classy if they're
just a big old piece of trash trash I'm
your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toies in the new edition I cannot get
her to stop rooting through the
Christmas presents okay she's looking
for the laraza pan that I got her okay
generic I presume see you got to wait
till Christmas day like everybody else
dut my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he is an international
businessman and he is not to be trifled
with in the boardroom or the bedroom
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what
up gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are TR
cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com garbage you go over
there you get all your bajillion hours
of bonus content gang and also too let's
not be remissed uh Town Hall New York
City tickets are on show right now the
biggest show we ever done get them
tickies let's go New York come out and
see the boys and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinary
old magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the te's and he
dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mccrs Toby McMullen everybody what up
boys excited I'm so excited one of my
favorite comedians on planet Earth in
here faite people just great dude when I
told I quit drinking I watched the light
leave his eyes I was upset I was truly
he pulls out his phone and deletes your
number who you who's going to go to
Oldtown na house with me for one
more every night all right man take care
it's good knowing you yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm sure it'll all work out for
you gang the long hair ain't lying we
couldn't be more excited Dev are
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today he's been
a minute we're [__] boys we love him
he's got a brand new special out right
now that you got to check out the
blue-eyed Mexican available on his
YouTube page and it was produced by
Leanne Cher and ber C it's available on
B's YouTube page you got to check it out
give it up for Mr Shane Torres everybody
let's go let's go here we are and here's
here's the Capper the last time you were
here it's been a while which I can't
believe early on in the show yeah you're
not going to believe it to look at you
guys take care boys here to say stuff
it deemed classy you were deemed classy
yeah I had to go back it was a few years
back right yeah yeah very earlier on in
the show we hadn't had the full you know
line of questioning down yet we were
still a little fresh to the game I was
like Kevin spy pulling it together
started limping out of there it's floss
or whatever
you whatever it is people don't do on
this
show now I got all my
teeth people ask us well who's been CL
classy and you we have a couple of like
standard answers like oh sagoro was
classy this one was cl never did we ever
think
yeah right I mean it's because is it
because we ate D wrapped hot dogs talk
well I forgot about that we did do that
in the middle of [__] man likes a
kach they are great yeah I love them
that wasn't a bues right no that was um
the uh Che stop not the che stop slov
slov that's how you know I'm actually
trash is cuz I know there's two rival
TR we're a buy family we walk in Shane
how you
doing man I forgot about that car ride
that we went to see the Cowboys game we
drove from Mo Tower in Austin and you
were going home to Dallas we were doing
a show in Dallas which is what that's
like a 4 hour maybe three and a half
yeah with the kach stop at let's be
honest the kalachi stop was the real
reason that we were all together and the
real real reason that we were going
there 70 minutes in a car some kind of
Hardy
snack dude like well we had we could
have took the highway and been there in
an hour we went Halfway Around Texas on
local roads it's it's a touch out of the
way but I think it'll be to get a
Ukrainian pastry in
Texas check we didn't know what they
were he's like kachi kachi we're like
all right whatever and we stopped and
it's like a Hot Pocket S Type it's like
a giant fancy pig in the blanket p and
you can get pepperoni you can get they
place makes their own sausage which is
like probably the best thing about like
they'll do jalapenos and cheese in them
they're like I mean they're like a Swiss
burrito or something sure yeah and I
mean I'm not even [__] around we
ordered about 14 that's what I say when
I
UNR Here Comes The Swiss
burrito you want mild or picante
sauce tell me but that yeah that was a w
yeah and then we went to the game then
we went to the Cowboys game yeah Monday
Night Eagles Cowboys at Cowboy at at the
Cowboys and the Eagles LW it was it was
a I think it it wasn't a it wasn't a
rope though like I think it was
competive but they ran away with it it
was closer than it looked we were booed
out of the stadium we I think we left
like halfway through the fourth quarter
yeah um we did leave early I also the
thing I also remember is us like going
completely around the Cowboy stadium is
massive so like we all got our steps in
oh yeah cuz we were like well it didn't
help when we got to the seats and the
three of us were all hunched in yeah
that was banana yeah d so we walked into
that place and we were walking into
Disney World like look at his joint oh
my god well I sitting next to you and
like I remember like two quarters into
the game you were like Jerry Jones is a
genius figured out a way to make
everybody pay 500 bucks bucks to watch
his big ass
TV shout out to him but Dan classy we go
we gota we got to dig back there's got
to be dirt under the finger nails for
sure yeah I think I got away with some
of it CU a lot of it was childhood based
and and and and you really pulled the wo
over our eyes on that you know what he
does it is very class that we've done a
handful of time it's a very gentleman
esque thing now that I think it it just
popped in my head we'll be somewhere
we'll run into each other doing spots
somewhere in the city and we'll have
like an hour each have like an hour or
two we're in between time we're in
between times and the whole I think
that's what they say about Alzheimer's
patience H grey mma's in between times
she thinks I'm a sailor she thinks it's
1942 she's are you going to the par
he'll do this thing where he invites you
out for a drink he does this like let's
go grab a beer then you get there and
you sit yeah it's very gentleman it's
not like it's not like drinking it's
enjoying each other's we're not getting
[__] face we're having like we're having
two ketchup cocktail then going ketchup
cocktail not the condiment
yeah you got a hindes on the Rocks but
it's very
like you see a guy like doing this into
a
hitting a 5 like you got to hit on the
57 so you dating anybody
now but it's very adult it's very like
we sit there we catch up we don't get
wasted and then we go on about our night
it's also like fun it's easier than like
yeah a like well there's nine of us here
so we should all like somebody wants to
do a shot yeah there's too many
variables with Southern gentlemen it's
very Metropolitan it's what you think
I'm very Metropol I'm hearing a rocky
three painting
I wore it for you guys thank you so much
oh God okay where are you living now
what you I'm I'm still in I mean I can't
remember when I was here last or like
what time but like I'm still in Bushwick
but uh I'm I'm over that [__] own place
or you got roommates I got a roommate
you got a roommate the special needs to
take
off let's go many I got I got one
roommate I'm I'm married to her I no I
got one roommate fck hold on that's
somebody's joke it's that somebody's
joke I'm sure it is it's kind of hacky
and the woman that lives with me no yeah
Ali sadik said
that the woman that lives in my house
lives in my house you ever hear Ron
White that where he goes somebody ask
like how many wives you got have you
been how many times have you been
married he goes four or five I can never
remember that tall one's
name that's all right I love me some Ron
White he the man he's the funniest
roommate one roommate but that's New
York that's yeah you can't trash that
yeah and my thing like I'm gone as much
as you guys so like I need somebody more
you got you're on the road all the time
I need somebody to throw out the tub of
lettuce I leave in the bridge that I
never [__]
eat there's a bowl of ramen in my room
you want to get that out of there it's
like liquefying and I've been home for
two days haven't tossed it what's the
what's the bed situation you got a king
you got a queen I got a queen you got a
queen temper Temperpedic okay uh that
was the first thing I ever spent money
on like when I got like five grand on
the mattress five G's on the [__] you
$5,000 Queen I really was doing well for
a I had a great month does it go up and
down or anything no not a hospital bed
Jesus there's just a a hogy suspended
and I rageed myself up for a bik put the
guard rails up at night got a Mountain
Dew IV like
dude 5
G's but I like I was like I don't know
why I Justified it to myself so much but
I spent a lot of money on the and by the
way it is not a $5,000 you don't get a
$5,000 night sleep well it is one of
those things they say you spend you know
whatever an eighth or uh a third of your
life in bed and so when you are home
you're on the road you're traveling so
much it's like when I'm home you want to
be comfortable like that's a thing to
spend money on and eth you'd sleep 20
minutes a night all strung out I got
some the other the other half is the
other 7 hours is eating and beating off
what's okay so $5,000 mattress yeah uh
do you have a fitted
sheet
yeah I got to follow I got to follow
protocol
Mr wild you have like a bag of raccoons
at your last
guess that's [__] insane a fitted she
are you bear backing it or what are you
doing I'm assuming if people get on this
podcast they have like a sheet they're
not paying for everything in Confederate
money or you
like who the [__] doesn't have a f she I
didn't for a long time well yeah a long
time we're we're we're men of means that
spend all this money on catchup
cocktails spend all this money on this
mattress I forgot to say something for
the pillow
[__] okay some towels wrapped around it
all right fitted sheet nice comforter
solid Pendleton nice like um he dropped
the name I don't you know like that's
like a it's like
um Western like uh shirt brand stuff but
they make blankets and stuff too but
like pretty good then you got have a
brand name comforter you guys both have
girls right so like I needed a a a
comforter that was not all one color cuz
that's what every guy it's always black
white or you know like or something and
to find one that is not just one
solidified color or like a have a Yankee
logo on it like like it's really
difficult to looks that looks masculine
you like so I like I spent a lot of time
researching I was like cuz I wanted
something when a woman walked into my
room they're like I got to [__] this guy
in a race car bed kind of energy I see a
really like Iron Man
huh your heads were Tony Stark's head
with he's got the Hulk gloves on I am
the suar
one yeah bro
protection
rocket launcher comes out of my
chest uh he's very C he's very
thoughtful and calculator which we found
in the scaling of things makes you not
garbage you you collect information and
you make decisions based upon that yeah
but I am I am garbage in like with what
we were talking about with food earlier
I'm garbage in like certain areas you
know certain Arenas yeah and I and I I'm
a Hall of Famer some of them what's the
room like if we walked into the room
right now is it SPI and span is it clean
it's I keep a tidy room but it's like a
it's also like got a little bit I want
to say like hoarder energy but there's
like random [__] in places you're like
what is this about okay can you give me
an example what are you talking about so
one of my w I bought a bucket of dry
erase paint so it's like you know what
this like yeah so it turns the wall into
a dry erase paint okay so my whole wall
is like a giant to-do list for work
purposes or doodling it's just it's a
list of sandwiches yeah
one
day I'll get that chicken farm but like
and then sometimes like so there'll be
like a list of like you're here this
week you're like you're doing this like
that kind of and then it'll also be like
you [__] idiot this person's got this
and you have nothing like so oh really
oh I like that it's like there's like
one one
thing well I was I was dating this girl
for a while and I wrote on the I was
really mad at somebody we all know I
like that I didn't know you had that you
got a grudge
yeah that's what I'm talking about I
wrote on the wall people are liars and
they will steal from you and she was
like what the [__] is this about man
you're cuckoo and I like yeah but I like
I get motivated things to do call the
FBI I get more motivated that way so
like no I like that for for I think five
years on the screen saver on my phone
was no one's coming to save you yeah and
I was at New York comedy club and some
some other comic saw that I was like
what the [__] is that like Steve bimy
and Billy Madison yes it's a little um
people are ling it's a little intense
sometimes I think like you know like
like Rayle
room laes out Dan you know some people
are like tough like like right like
tough times Never Last tough people do
like it's like that but like the reverse
with a tinge of uh you're like like yeah
that's awesome it's not going great suck
my dick [__] yeah it's not about
optimism for me it's about motivation
sure people people will lie stab you in
the
back hey great Mee your mother never
loved you your mother never loved you
okay all right that's a thing um shared
bathroom in the apartment uh one and a
half bath one and a half bath uh how
long will you use your towel for let's
say you're home for a little while
you're home for um a few weeks how how
many how many runs home and how many do
you own I have four towels probably but
I got I got sing that's pretty good I'm
a big dude I'm a big dude and I got long
hair so like that's like but I will use
at least two towels every shower really
cuz the hair like the hair just stays
wet so I need to like wrap it up like I
do the mom lady thing do yeah and you do
the towel around you too yeah but up
here
so I do it I do it through the
top cover the
bags he got some of I give a little they
see a Little Neck see a little
wow and so how many times will you use
both of those towels before you wash
them uh like a week maybe two weeks like
that's showering every day but yes but I
also like I get I drop my laundry off
because I'm gone so much I wouldn't do
it that much it's easy for me to do the
because I just throw it all in when I
come home yeah so it's like it's a
little bit of a cheat okay yeah but it's
efficient yeah it's pretty you don't
blow dry the hair no and are you
flossing every day no never not even
like when's the last is there any floss
in your apartment there I got the sticks
okay yeah yeah okay but that's as needed
or you know well past sure yeah yeah
they're still onop I [__] hate
flossing I it's grow it hurts it's the
only thing that I do on a regular basis
really the only good I don't know why
it's the only good habit that I have I
have to mentally floss before I brush my
teeth otherwise I don't feel like I've
brushed my teeth see I should like try
and implement it in the way where I'm
thinking about it like of course I do it
when I'm I should brush my teeth of
course that's when I should do it but
I'm just so [__] lazy on your wall
sometimes I honest to God sometimes I
know I need to brush my teeth dental
floss wants to kill you B again I like
but I'll like eat food like I'll have
eaten food I'm like I'm tired and I just
like sleep oh yeah I'm I'm better
brushing my teeth at night before I go
to bed is that [__] so sad it's crazy
feel the one thing like our mothers
tried to install in all of us and I
can't brush your teeth before you go to
bed it feels good though it feels
naughty dude to what to not do it feels
I do that with my contacts too I'll
sleep in them I'm a dirty little dirty
little [__] does that hurt uh these he
legally blind but no I have daily ones
now but for a long time I had like
weeklys and monthlies and I would sleep
in them and every once in a while I
would cut my cornea and I would be in
agonizing pain for like 48 Hours brutal
I would have to hold my eye to an air
conditioner to to keep it cold ke let's
talk about Helix shout out to Helix I
slept in one last night might have sh
[__] to bed woo gang if it
what what do you want from I'm
broadcasting here it's a great mattress
Dang if a helix is not on your Christmas
lift you're a goddamn idiot cuz it's the
best night sleep you ever had get some
shuty do yourself a favor reach out to
Santa write him a letter send them a
fact send them an email something do
whatever you got to do send one of those
Chinese space balloons up there to the
North Pole say hey Pops send a helix to
the kid cuz they are comfy uh yeah it's
sorry I got the California King sleep
sleeping it every night uhhuh woo
we
okay I have three of them at this point
I got two at the house and a BBS I got
one at this place and one at my wife's
boyfriend's house I want him comfortable
guys just take a quick little quiz on
their she was coming back with a bad
back and their experts will let you know
what will give you she's going to be
upset about that we'll give you the best
night's sleep whether you're a big and
tall sleeper like the big man you run
hot you want helix's cooling technology
whatever you want they got you covered
so right now Helix is offering 20% off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for are you garbage listeners go to
helixsleep.com garbage use the code
Helix
partner2 and that's helixsleep.com
garbage code Helix partner 20 this is
their best offer yet and it won't last
long with Helix better sleep starts now
do it do it this episode of Ru garbage
is brought to you by better Heth gang
sometimes life seriously sucks yep we
all know that you get jammed up
especially around the
holidays start feeling that you know
what helps talk therapy baby get on the
phone get on the text privacy your own
home get on better help and talk it out
yeah if you've never uh have done talk
therapy just give it a shot once
everybody's got gets a tight head you
get upset you get mad you're frustrated
job work whatever Family Trust Me family
drives you up a freaking wall uh but the
therapy friends to it's a great tool you
can use it for a couple of weeks you can
try it out whatever you can use a
longterm whatever you need their therapy
is completely online so you can meet
with a counselor wherever and whatever
works for you uh if you want to be on
your car your lunch break great you can
meet with your therapist over a video
call phone call or even message to get
started take the quiz on their website
and better help experts will match you
with a therapist if their first pick
isn't a winner you can switch at any
time no questions asked in the season of
giving give yourself what you need with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com garbage
a day to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp HP / garbage do it
ging do it how often do you guys change
your sheets well they got the birds yeah
see it's it's inter you're a single guy
so anything you do better than yeah like
my my sheets could like fold out like a
like a tray of freshly made pasta
like so you don't wash the sheets not as
much as I should it's like yeah it's
like once a month I change them that a
sing like I'm disgusting sure I get it
but as again I don't think I ever washed
my sheets when I was [__] when I was
living I would wear I would use them
till they were horrible and then I'd put
them on I'd buy go byy new one until I
was like these are unsalvageable and not
that long ago twice in there within the
last eight years I was sleeping on just
a mattress I didn't have a fitted
sheet I actually kind of like it or I
kind like I don't think I had pillow you
like the texture of the rough yeah like
the feel of it you're like a bear just
scratching
himself you know what I learned my wife
taught me that I don't know I didn't
know is you're supposed to I think the
common thing is like if you buy bed
sheets you wash them before you put them
on oh yeah I hate that I washed my
clothes before I put them on I I don't
never do I've never ever done that with
any package thing really goes right on
the bed a beach towel anything I use
right I got I got to wash my t-shirts
before I C my hamburger
meat right packaged to
mou hamburger meat oh you hamburg meat
the Trashy version ground beef set of
ground beef oh yeah that is yeah I
wouldn't even ARG Mr four towels over
here huh got this guy
napkins Burger King
napkins okay huh your hamburger meat is
TR hamburger meat is trash it is it's a
[__] yeah it's like they don't know it
comes from a cow yeah we were asking the
other day what's the thing that you look
in in the car to see what's behind you
what's the a rear view
oh I'd say I'd say rearview mirror you
do say mirror yeah not rearview mirror
mirror I'd say mirror Mir you's got the
r yeah I I get I finished the word
when oh I'm
sorry yeah I say review mirr yeah Mirror
Mirror Mirror m e is this an accent
thing or is this like a trashy thing a
trashy thing it's a trashy dialect here
take a beat and say it naturally go
ahead re mirror he says mirror no he's
got the other R in there it's real he he
does it like me it's me e e r o r yeah
mirror okay it's not Mirror Mirror riew
viewing hello my view triangle
is huh okay is your phone screen
currently cracked no but that is a bless
like that it has been so many time it's
just not currently okay where do you put
the towel when when you're when you're
done with it you hang it over your
bathroom door or do you have a place for
it I I got h hook a hook that hangs off
the bathroom door but often times I will
like I'll shower and then I'll just be
like in the towels like laying on my bed
like I've done that yeah that ain't
Cassy feels real fresh though it feels
like a like a good wet
blanket all right uh are you biting the
nails or do you clip them oh I'm these
are just like little anxiety
sure oh like crazy where do the bitten
if you're in your house if you're
hanging out in the room you're hanging
out in the living room bite a nail
where's it going
cares [__] ask me these questions
okay you you he's on his own yeah they
they go wherever I'm at like I [__]
it's it's a crime scene it
is [__] cares you're going to get mad
at me about that do you even love me
that's true if you can't have me in my
wor but that's like a thing you guys
have girls so like I think that'd be a
bit more I get yelled at they they I'm
also it is gross but it is a bachelor
thing sure I will try to do it I will
try to hopefully there's some sort of
empty water bottle around me or a soda
something I can put them in hold up
putting them into something that should
be recycled is [__] disgusting what
do you
mean like so you clip them and then
you're like I don't clip them I'm biting
them you're biting them or but they're
coming off they're coming off spitting
them in their like sunflower seeds yeah
hillbilly taking dip
just I think it's it's it's as gross as
when someone you're leaving them on the
floor yeah behind the couch is the
correct answer that's the Gent I get
yelled at for that cuz then she'll clean
behind the couch and then I get a rash I
always get excited about that like I
can't wait till we finally pull this
couch out in vacuum to see I kind of
think about it that way too and then
sometimes like if you hear like it suck
up and it's like and you hear me like
that's a lot of that's a lot of me I
also have this weird thing freaks I also
have this weird thing that if if my
fingernails somewhere and civilization
gets wiped out and aliens come they
might find my fingernail and and and
recreate me clone me or something he
said that to me one the first times I
met him and I've never looked at him the
same I I thought we were going to chill
you think they're going to come back and
like we're going to go to this apartment
in what used to be queens and Jurassic
Park Us in h
Foley just annoying everybody hey what's
up with all your weird spindly
fingers you guys got fitted cheats
what's in there you got hamburger meat
in that thing all right are there any uh
are there any milk crates in your
apartment for storage record for sure
yeah what's in it is is it records it's
there's records but the skulls of my
enemies sitting down with
PR um yeah there's there uh the records
and like some and there's another one
with like cleaning [__] in it okay okay
yeah and then uh the records are also we
have a bunch of them they're also on a
bookshelf that's sideways though like
down so that's kind of
not it's a curve single guy it's a curve
can you tell that it's the bottom of it
isn't on the ground you kind I don't I
don't think you would notice honestly it
looks it's like it's it looks like like
it belongs the way it is I think but uh
no woman is no woman in my apartment has
ever noticed it yeah so that that's like
yeah all right have you do you have now
or have you ever had a Foot
Locker no no never had foot that's you
mean at theed yeah I'm a
gii like grandpa had this in the war L
it all across
Europe we had it when we were kids a
bunch of Nazi memorabilia when I open
something yeah bunch of German
fingernails okay fair enough uh will you
dance at a wedding I do now you do now
yeah I do now what now what's the caveat
what what like it's like a it's like a
thing I didn't do it for so long and I
was like what are you doing have fun yes
yeah but it I am if I dancing I am lit
for sure you're Hamed and I
like open bars are a SC or a bar
bartenders at weddings is a scam it
soaks but I make sure my friends get
their money at a like what do you mean
my friend told me the dollar the dollar
amount my buddy told me at his wedding
per head for the bar was $66 a person is
what he had to pay like and I was like
there I was like there's I for sure
drank like $300 worth of so like
you're up there going while a Michelob
the street I was taking shots out of
wine glasses like I and this was also
this wedding was at the last place
Amelia airheart was ever seen
alive in the air or just like at a store
yeah like it at the store no like this
was a like a a speaking like some
historical building in La they're like
she spoke here the night before she like
flew and no one ever saw her someone
just told us that too yeah yeah someone
just mentioned that to we were just
right there somewhere I got Dr no I was
talking about the ailia airart lookout
in Hawaii no I know but it happened in
La I remember someone's like ailia
Airhart was right here yeah I can't
remember where though yeah it was uh Ian
carmel's wedding if you guys know him I
don't know if he he wrote I mean know
yeah but yeah um Okay I uh I'm a big
proponent of that too of it was
instilled in me early from a a booze bag
family of I've never met an open bar I
haven't beat yeah like so like do oh I
mean dude even an open bar even at like
a resort if they're like it's $1,000 do
for the week but it's open you know it's
open free food and free beer I'm like
I'm I'm leaving with something you guys
think that's like on the cruises when
they do the like the booze like how much
booze you excuse me everyone who buys
the booze package like the Supreme one
was like 700 bucks but you get drink all
you want for 4H you think the move is
like everyone just gets ripped because
like they're like we don't have to pay
for anything so on the second day
they're like their intake drops like you
see like it's like you know like the
first night of every Comedy Festival
you're like I'm not getting trash and
then you get [__] shitfaced and then
the next day you're like I'm chilling
yeah so they're like oh we'll take 700
bucks for your first night you're going
to drink $30 a second that's not bad I
think it's a Shifty Cruise Line move wow
could be I don't know but Cruise people
get after it that's why they're there
it's their Super Bowl they've been
looking forward to it I've never been on
one but it looks I mean we did we did we
did BS and I mean I saw the you guys
looked beat I almost went to his room on
the second night and asked for my check
in advance I was [__] losing money we
were losing
capsized B make good with that cash
let's go oh cuz you guys were playing
black jacket we were playing Let It Ride
when n neither one of us knew what it
was I that is a trash was like put it
all on
whatever all the tables were full and I
sat it was empty and I sat down I'm like
hey man you got got to teach me how to
play and I didn't really get it then I
told him the guy who's taking your money
is going to teach you how to play first
thing give me your
watch uh text your wife get that prenom
what do you uh you stay at hotels a lot
yeah uh do you leave anything for the
for the
cleaning yeah always what do you do I um
it depends like I am not it's usually at
like 10 bucks if it's three days I don't
get my room service though really unless
they come in like if I'm gone I don't
and uh a lot of times I strip the sheets
off the beds for them when I'm done what
I just like it's like they work hard man
like these [__] people I think like I
just like one out I would i' say one out
of every four throw the towels in a
corner yeah like I don't but I also
don't like messy [__] so like I like if
I have the towels like I put you guys
might like just work out of your
suitcases when you're in your hotel room
like everything go in the dresser with
me and I hang my [__] really really yeah
yeah what well if how what's the the
minimum nights that you have to be there
to do that one are you on one I will
forest
forest yeah why'd you put your clothes
so fast into the dresser airs I tell The
Bag Man to come up and bring my foot
locker and I unpack my dress board
that's nuts so two nights you're you're
unloading
yeah I've never but I'm always
performing I don't like my [__] to be
wrinkled like you know like I look it's
a
[__] it's a bad enough house to look
at in any neighborhood so like I hey I'm
with you baby you got to make sure to
shut like you know when you see a shitty
home and some guy really takes pride in
his lawn sure sure that's that's the
logic I'm with you on that but I never I
it's always like 10 if I'm there for
like five days it's like 20 you know
like sure bar five bucks a night in and
around there give or take whatever you
have on you they work hard man and
that's a thankless [__] job I also
steal off their carts all the time you
soap so so yeah cuz I use like uh a lot
of like soap and conditioner and then I
also like we take their
purse picture of her son bottle wind
grab her birth control but I like I like
to take the stuff and then I I bring it
home and I like uh like I donate the
shampoos and stuff you do yeah like I'll
take them to a shelter or like a with
like because like you know like we use
this [__] all the time they just end up
in our bags I'm sure you guys just have
R like they just it's sitting in your
place right so I don't take much of it
yeah I mean I like that I took it a lot
when I was poor sure and now I just it's
a habit and I just like it's like this
should go to like a shelter or something
like I just donating it's I mean I'm
stealing to I'm doing the wor Robin and
he wasy but here's the thing though
was he was British if you ever walk by
those carts and they're out there hey
can I grab a yeah go ahead they don't
give yeah and like I'm also like I have
this weird thing where like I'm like
this is all bad for the environment you
know like it's so like I'm like well I
might as well go to the person who's in
the worst environment sure yeah you're
you're such a sweetheart that's nice
though I don't know if it's classy it's
just
like listen I ain't never donated
nobody Don it to anybody I don't think
so he steals from homeless shelters I
played a lottery every now and then that
benefit that benefits signs that say get
a job holy [__] and you use turns of
phrases like a bad house in any
neighborhood you say you say adorable
like you be like oh man that donut don't
glaze yeah Southern gentl who suck the
jelly atdi old
Donut they drunk her to three skunks on
a Possum's back
what
man
oh y making me laugh like the
Dickens you do say that I have heard you
say
theck yeah he hit you with a sales pitch
boom okay man that's uh that's pretty
good when you're at a restaurant will
you stack the plates for the server
sometimes but not if it's cluttered like
I say I don't like like a I don't like
clutter so it needs to you the four of
us are at a table and there's like a
bunch of we get three appetizers and
everything is like bounding up we're
getting more three appetizers what are
you talking about what we're all looking
good we're doing better it's the
holidays everyone eats and drinks more
it's
fine uh don't [__]
Jud he loses it you're going to be end
up on the wall you're going to be on the
wall of the room I consolidate to like
cuz I don't like the I don't it really
it irks me a lot so I can't so that's I
think that's why the hotel room stuff
too like it feels more uniform got
strips the sheets huh do you own any
suits like if you had to go for a
wedding tomorrow what are you
wearing uh I have no two no I have two I
have two
uh one is a was like a funeral suit like
you just got to and then the other one I
got and I don't know why I have it and
it fits so [__] bad like it is like
the buttons are screaming
on I like that you have a death I do I
do a real
like a dude I hate that it's like I'm
snapping a
football ah it's the worst especially
with the dress pants when they [__] you
with the hook on the back you got to go
that you got to go that extra half an
and then yeah that and also it's just
like if it doesn't work and you have the
button only if the hook comes undone
it's sitting out there like a little
failure brutal feel it rubbing against
you the whole time [__] hate that
[__] it's amazing how like as big as I
am how conscious I have of the littlest
thing touching me and like weirding me
out like that like if it's a little
tight I'm like yeah it's you it's
emotional you feel you're like oh it's
sticking it's whatever yeah yeah I never
looked like I belong in a suit I don't
I'm I'm not we it's this has been a long
running theme on the show of like fat
guys in suits you only look good the
best you look is that second you look in
the mirror you go I'm ready from then on
it's downhill stay away it's downhill
God forbid you got to get into a car to
get where you're going everything's
[__] wrinkled straight to the
bathroom for a ret I feel like every
step I take in suit pants is like maybe
like a like a ship that's about to get
like a b cut into it like it just I feel
like it's going to tear any the [__]
rivet start Ping my pants are as tight
as an athlete with a great asses
like [__] show it off if you got it
yeah you're just [__] hugging me dude
it's awful do you know how to tie a
tie not really not not without I can do
it with like a YouTube video yeah but I
know no h what's the nice Sho situation
at the house you got nice uh dress shoes
I got one pair and they're
like they're obviously out of place on
other thing like they go with the suit
that I bought them with but yeah yeah
but they're not like I can't if you guys
were like you know dress nice what would
let's say you're not you have no suit
what are you dressing nice in we're
going to like a nice dinner yeah going
to a nice dinner what what are you
throwing on what did I wear on
Conan that was seven years ago just show
up in a grant hill
Jersey like I mean it's just like a it's
a button- down of some like a it's like
they're
like uh like Phil you know they're like
uh what is that company duth or whatever
you know they're kind of like it's a
fine quality shirt but it is not a nice
it's it's the way a lumberjack looks
good I got you I got you when was the
first time you had
Nutella I don't know but I do remember
people talking about it and I'll be like
oh yeah I didn't know what it was and I
never thought about yeah it's the best
like I I do that with so much [__] me
too I recommend books I haven't read
it's great oh all I count documentaries
as
books I like it yeah you know that
Penguin book yeah that was so would you
say you were an adult but the first time
you had
Nutella 100% yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
and I also I thought it was healthy the
way the people that I was like I'm still
convinced it's not it's not not healthy
talk about mint M baby shout out to that
mint
mobile talk about the top of my
Christmas LIF it's Mt mobile you want to
know why how much you think the plans
are I don't know a 100 bucks a month
loser 15 bucks a month they start plans
at you want to know why no brick and mor
it's all online pass the savings right
onto you look at that uh as always all
the plans come with unlimited talk text
highspeed Data all delivered on the
nation's largest 5G network babyg not
the smallest the largest that's what
they're doing over there in Mt mobile
big they do it big uh right now when you
switch to M mobile you buy any 3-month
plan will'll give you another 3 months
for free so that's 6 months of Premium
wireless service for the price of free
uh price of three it's fantastic I've
been saying it for years I've been a c
my family's been a customer before they
were before this podcast even existed
check the tapes uh so it's easy to
switch uh all you have to do is change
your phone you don't you don't it's easy
to switch I apologize you don't have to
change your phone or your phone number
the only thing that changes is your bill
for a limited time buy any 3month mint
Mobile plan and get three more months
free by going to mintmobile.com garbage
that's mintmobile.com garbage cut your
wireless Bild to just 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com garbage do it gang do
it Kip you know about Aura frames do I
know about it I love it of course you do
you got the bird one you got Mom one
everybody gets an order frame you want
to know why cuz it's a digital picture
frame that you can load up and you can
keep it going you got playlist it's not
like those Dusty old photos you can pull
out a nice old picture of you like
coming out of the shower with the doing
the the mohawk with the shampoo it's a
good time listen uh it's a fantastic
product and it's such a fantastic
product and EAS it makes it an easy gift
it's a it's a thoughtful thoughtless
gift if that makes sense it's easy it
comes in you about a bing you about a
boom they get it they love it it's
One-Stop shop you don't have to go here
and there and there bada bing bada boom
you get it it comes in a nice little
package ship it send it right to them
they open it up and and they [__]
themselves and you could keep you keep
up with the family if you don't live
near them yeah guys if you're looking
for a a Christmas present or a holiday
present for someone on for a lady on
your list a mom a mother-in-law a
sister-in-law a wife a girl it's the
aura frame they think you're a hero yeah
uh this holiday season listeners can
save on the perfect gift by visiting Ora
frames.com garbage that's Aura a
frames.com garbage use promo code
garbage to get $30 off their bestselling
frames get yours now before they sell
out cuz they're probably going to terms
and conditions apply do it do it could
the same be uh said for or Orangina do
you remember the first time you had an
Orangina I don't even know what that is
really it's like an I'm not even
honestly sure it's like a it's like a
Sunny D it's a drink it's a European
soda oh it's European I believe so can
you give that a goo I I equated to Sunny
D throw your laptop against the wall I
think it's European or they Market it
like it was your it seemed like a
classier soda oh it's like a like the
way they're they're kind of churching it
up exactly it's like a light sparkling
orange drink it's French it's French
there you go then no I
haven't [__]
frogs hey they make good frog my
grandfather goes over there bust brings
me his Foot Locker so I can drink a
lightly a stupid hat okay all right
when'd you get your
passport oh um that's good oh
2013 who [__] for comedy purposes yeah I
got I got just for I got new faces
that's why I got [__] all right and
I that passport my birthday is the 4th
of October and for some reason my four
looked like a nine so I had um illegal
document that I was traveling with for
like no [__] yeah cuz the birthday was
off for a decade I got it fixed this
year so Jesus yeah all right huh okay so
I don't know if that's CL that's bad
right me like if it's a problem you know
it's going to happen again and again you
got it in your 20s yeah yeah that's not
great yeah that's not what I mean I had
one when I was like nine because my mom
was from Ireland so but like oh that's
right so like but then we we you know we
stopped going there like after my folks
War so I was like probably 13 like I
never used it past 11 Goa so I had one
to before but like also we never would
have had passports if my mom hadn't been
from like if my mom traveled
internationally as a young kid that's
pretty good probably moving guns for the
IRA or something
but it's also what the devil are you
talking about I think that I we've he
had it laps though that's crazy that
seems more nuts to me than not having it
you had it but I was like 13 if you're
13 and then you're going to
see I feel like that's something you
stay on top of let me put this in
perspect I I got mine at
45 I was 45 when I got my passport I can
see
that 45 he got a
where did you go please tell me you like
you thought you were going to Puerto
Rico and you thought you needed
one
Ola California it's like Island Mexico I
went to France oh to get some orina I'm
thinking of going there uh next month oh
buddy you being serious yeah cuz I don't
I have like a break in the schedule and
like I'm promoting like crazy right now
and I'm like something like maybe like
do little something for you yeah but I
don't want to go alone like you know
like it's awesome Paris is awesome
I'm sure it's beautiful but I'm like I
don't want to be like the American guy
who shows up like alone like like I'm
going to meet the love of my life you
know I don't want to be like this guy
keeps taking all the sheets off the beds
just keep randomly bumping into people
hoping it's the love of your life oh my
God see up all these street performers
calling them
Heroes just knocking lady's purses over
so you try and touch your hand while
your hel back
together said I'll just go to Montreal
and E hisp
I did it all one day it was a big deal
all right ah man do you know how to use
chopsticks [__] no no not I'm not bad
I'm like bad at I'm really bad at like I
can do it but it's it's I me it's like
it's like the kid you put in right field
like sometimes he's going to catch it
sometimes he's not yeah is there a go-to
karaoke song uh uh Build Me Up
Buttercup man that's a fun one that
that's a drinking like everybody gets
involved like that's the win is that
it's it's it's for yes yeah yeah I
respect that uh what's the whistling
with your fingers situation can you do
it uh no no no I'm I get too hungry and
then I just
startling can you whistle at all uh yeah
like but it's not good it's like sh like
that's classy not being able to do
that's classy you think so what whistle
with your fingers can you whistle with
your fingers no I it's I can't whistle
at all I've I've always been envious of
that what does that guy usually do how
does that guy usually end up he
screaming at the kid that you knew he
drives a boat that's a taxi yeah the kid
that you knew that could go when he was
a kid yeah he is not a doctor he had a
tattoo from his
uncle there you go kind of [__] yeah are
you are you currently signed up into any
free
trials
wait does digital count like if you're
like a Hulu free trial fre trial for
sure I am for sure I have been in my
free trials on a million subscription
services that I have not cancelled I'm
also part of a class action lawsuit the
[__] oh for who the big one just came
out that everybody's doing uh the AG the
travel insurance company that oh they
got jammed up yeah tar had one going
with like Ry Larita or something like
that what did he have yeah no Li Marita
he got like 18 bucks or something 18
Rita bucks he he was suing a Buffalo
Wild Wings just like their equivalent of
maror M you to use it on the website
wait AGI what what a is like a you know
when you check out you're like do you
want to insurance insurance ensure your
flight I always do no because I have
stat but like this is one of those ones
like I was like I did it with something
cuz I think maybe I was running a car or
something like that that's what it was
it was a one of those when I was rening
a car they're like do you want to insure
and I was like yeah cuz cuz I'm going to
have it for like s days in La so it's
probably best and then it was like uh so
you just check yes and they add 10 bucks
a day to the car or whatever but it's
like one of these things like they were
charging these things called like
um service fees or something like that
but it's like this thing of like an
astronomical rate of like 70% of like
they were like really they were like MLM
level kind of like diing people on it so
I mean I think I'm going to I'm I'm in
one but it's like a $22 like these
things are not payouts for this is not
going to how did you get involved in
that did they reach out to you cuz cuz
they use like M Shane are you sitting
down were you about to say this is not
going to be the one like you're waiting
on a case to change your life blow it
wide
open and also the pointing does not
help I don't appreciate the accusation
you can sit back there in your Ivory
Tower if you want but I yeah like it's a
lot of like uh like I was like yeah this
is it's going to be like a $25
settlement if they called you to testify
would you go
100% so there I am I'm I look for any
kind of
attention he's up there he's up there
doing the guy Fier bit wearing his
funeral suit oh ah huh have you ever
saved a cigar box for
storage
yes ever written your name and W it's
fill it's filled with keys and concert
sub tickets probably why keys I don't
you know sometimes you just have a bunch
of keys
they don't fit [__] anymore what what
wait they're trophies from his victims
you're really falling apart
here we got like I said it's been a
rough few years haven't seen my friends
in a while maybe anyone checked
in wouldn't have to drag myself across
the Finish
Line Hey Keys man we really got you out
to deep water and and you you start
drowning you guys got a three-piece I'm
playing sing I'm just shooting free
throws alone
ticket stubs I get yeah uh if I was in
somebody's house and I saw a cigar box
full of keys I'd probably leave I would
have run I would check my pockets and
back out of the door it's like it's a
yeah it's a fair amount but they all go
to something and I'm like cuz I you I
only see that [__] when I'm like moving
or cleaning St like de cleaning my house
so I'm like well maybe I'll find the
thing that this tiny key goes to and I'm
like and then I'll see like a bike lock
and I'm like now well I should probably
throw this away I mean and then I just
don't if they were door keys that's one
thing that they're the tiny lck I mean
they're all kinds of keys they're
good I think we finally found I'm so
embarrassed by this and I never have
been truly have never been like I was
like this is normal it's so funny when a
comic a great comic mind who's whose
whole life is to defend points of view
and actions and he he literally all
could come up with you guys don't have
never had keys and you don't don't know
what they go to I not a box full I got a
couple sure I mean it's not like a
[__] Game of Thrones kind of thing or
like dungeon master yeah I'm not but
it's less than 100 for sure
100 it's less than 100 seven I'd give
you seven I don't think I've ever had
100 keys in I would give you a couple
from your last apartment that's the
leeway that's you dude what you have a
hundred things with locks on them you
the Postmaster
General I yeah I don't I don't I mean I
don't have 100 things but I have 100
keys that go to
theud [__] that's crazy I also I find
keys to be like sentimental for some
reason and I can't remember what
they they're like they're like
jewelry funny all right all right will
you wear clothes and return them if you
have like if you got something going on
no if I buy something like returning
something at the the store is like or
sending something back at a restaurant
is to me I'm like not if you guys did it
I would be like okay like they're my
friends but I would be very I'm usually
I'm usually very embarrassed by it oh I
am too somebody [__] it up so bad if
they bring you the chicken and you order
the like yeah that but but like taking
things back I don't think I also don't
want to deal with like burgers medium
you wanted it medium rare you're not who
gives a [__] like these people are
working like you know but like it's also
this also might be I've never done it
with food but like if I bought
like well hold on I just remember this
some
keys you know when you order a box of
keys blank Keys blank Keys the
possibility they can all be cut and
shaped into whatever you want it's kind
of like a metaphor for your
life but some of them don't ever shape
out they and then no door opens and you
have a
roommate I did go to to uh I was in
Austin I went to best but I had to do a
podcast and I didn't have my mic so I
went and bought one with the intention
of returning it that's okay that's on
that's when back that's playing the game
when I brought it back though the girl
was like why are you returning this and
I was like what like they think that's
like they think that's going to stand up
in a quarter of law well I think they're
they they I I got defensive about it
like cuz I don't want it mhm and and
then she goes oh we have to see if
they're defective like they can't put
them back on the Shelf no it's more of
like a quality control thing like were
they not working you I that's how I know
like I'm like a piece of [__] in some
way like or have been it's because I'm
like they automatically think I'm doing
a grift which I
am but they don't know that it's a beard
trimmer in the Box I was on Co bear lady
I don't need this for you put on your
blue shirt and get the [__] out of my
face I was on Co
bear uh huh have you ever had one of
those hoodies with the thumb hole or the
thumb sleeve for sure oh wow yeah you
must have no you're a [__] liar I can
see it from a mile away on
you okay now that I yep I did and I cut
them myself yeah a lot of people were
cutting them themselves dirt bag mine
came uh mine came uncut or I always
thought that was like a hot chick move
no it was like a skater Punk thing yeah
but it was definitely like a thing cute
girls did I think they still do like I
think hot chicks still have like the
over stuff is coming fashion from our
youth is coming back a bit I like that
yeah do breakfast in
bed do you eat in your room uh rarely in
my room in my I don't want to do this is
a bit on the special but I
do get my hotel room I always get with
two beds so I can eat in one of them all
right and use it as a napkin I'm yeah
that's class okay yeah that's wait as a
hold on you use what as a napkin the bed
sheets really why he's taking them off
yeah wow
that's that that might be how that
started hold on a second well you got a
famous Daves across the street what am I
going to
do wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute all right okay so you're just
taking the sheet and wiping and oh yeah
I'm like I do the I do a bit on the so I
don't want to like the but like yeah
100% I'll be like and just like
really this guy's coming apart at the
seams here you well I've been alone like
I said no one checked in on me
huh man will you buy stuff at the duty
free shop just so I'm I'm just curious
right now I don't know how far into the
game we are you're not doing great but
am I way behind or can
I can I get a last second field goal off
let's just say that if you were to pull
this out ESPN would make a documentary
about an unbel it would be like there'
be a 30 for 30 I think you would have to
dedicate a wing of AOS I'm fine as long
as it's not a Netflix
Untold you would need a a couple of
touchdown and a couple of onsides kicks
so like my winning percentage on the
meter is dropping like yeah if anybody
wants to make crazy money right now put
20 on
Tores it's 5,000 to one dude 20 on
Tores let's see if I can WRA it up if
you're but ask me if I
read if you're eating at the house you
do it on the couch watching TV yeah yeah
coffee table is there any hot sauce on
that coffee table a lot of the time
there is okay that just stays there
no not what no some people live like
that yeah just the cond of ketchup might
stay out there because it's like you you
take the dishes to the thing and then
that's no no no no no no no it all goes
back to a place okay how many what's the
what's the silverware set in the
apartment now there's a curve single guy
mostly mostly matching mostly matching
that's pretty good how many Forks would
you say you
have I think we have a half dozen of
every utensil is you know that's pretty
good four to Eight's per Eight's a lot
if you have eight you also don't need
needs eight spoons you know unless yeah
sure and so let's say you make something
are you cleaning it right away and
putting everything
back 70 30 like 7030 yeah before I go to
bed most of the time it gets clean okay
all right I'll well if I'm
cooking it gets clean that night for
sure okay yeah all right cuz I don't
like I worry about bugs and [__] sure
sure where uh what was the last uh Uber
Eats or post like somebody's making a
little
com you know they're not quite out of
this yet
Al the pass rush holds we'll
be what was the last delivery meal you
got oh man um man I would never answer
that are we talking a mount or cuisine
just give me the name of the joint uh
yeah I like that plead the
fifth El Pastor okay yeah all right
there you go and did you you don't have
to answer did you go tacos burritos I go
giant
burrito lots of chips and salsa and
usually like um an aqua it's your
heritage can you imagine an Irish themed
like like a real Irish fast food rather
just Wendy's funny I don't like this
line of questioning to be honest with
you no no I was start defending J don't
answer that no I asked for the place and
then I just asked for the tight the what
I you SOS in what the order is no he
volunteered that I said did you go tacos
or burrit like I didn't ask quanti but I
go a lot I like what I like it's the
only good Mexican food I have in New
York like cuz I think most the mexan
food here is [__] so I will go I'll eat
myself into pain okay yeah I've been the
buddy me too I'm right there with you
you know somebody said to me the other
day like [__] Bert of all people goes
we were talking about my way and goes
you know like but you only eat when
you're hungry I was like do you think
I'm fat cuz I only eat when I'm hungry I
hide it real well like the craziest
thing ever like fat people aren't fat
cuz they only eat when they're hungry
it's bananas that's like I'm constantly
overfilling my tank I remember I heard
this girl's like oh Kevin never eats and
I was like 310 lbs I was just like yeah
I'm doing it at midnight by myself at a
McDonald's just a light from a fridge
open I'm not doing it at the dinner with
everybody trying to hold it together a
little bit Yeah Keep Up Appearances huh
I mean I got one or two left as a
formality at this point as a formality
anybody in the family have an associates
degree just an associates degree do you
have I am the
closest I that's
it I am definitely the
closest a three credit shy baby buddy I
don't know what to tell you oh God it's
getting rough but you lost a class
action lawsuit with a you're trash it
also took me five years to graduate high
school
Jesus
oh man I love you but you are you fell
apart at the seams Co was difficult for
a lot
of he really got away with it for a long
time you're like Whitey Bulger you've
been on the Run you've been on a run
from us for about two years picked up
long pick me up in Long Beach wearing a
track suit with a bike beer tangle hat
and a pair of
sunglasses nine toes out of the car put
your hands up man ah man Mr Shane Torres
we love you bud the special is the blue
Mexican it's on your YouTube page it was
produced by lean and Berke Cher it's
also on Bert's YouTube page one of the
funniest guys working one of the
funniest guys out there you got to check
out the special if you haven't already
Mr Shane Torres thank you guys thank you
so much what else you got coming up uh
whatever you want website I got okay
yeah shanis comedian. comom uh Shane
tourus across all the social media
platforms I have a podcast with the
Great Kyle canine called no accounting
for Taste where we defend things that
people think are uh um corny or yeah
yeah like like like Disney adults or
something like that we try to figure out
why people do and then um I'm touring a
lot I got the new special out bluee
Mexican on YouTube M and B's Channel
That's the huge thing so if you guys see
it share like it check it out gang he's
one of the best one of the best one of
the absolute best one of the greatest
hangs of all time as well we can't thank
you enough for being here
congratulations we love you buddy Kippy
what do you got for him uh guys again
Town Hall Theater New York City let's
sell that [__] thing out uh we
[__] love you we appreciate you it's
our biggest show to date uh thank you
for all the support see you next week
gang peace peace